[MUSIC PLAYING]
JONNY CRANMER: Hi
everybody, and welcome
to this Talks at Google.
I am very excited to been
introducing two very cool guys
this morning that I've had
the pleasure to talking to
in the past.
And I will introduce them.
My name is Johnny Cramner and
I work in the Google LA office.
And it's my pleasure to
be talking with you guys
this morning.
So Joshua Fields Millburn
and Ryan Nicodemus,
better known as the minimalists,
help over 20 million people
live meaningful lives with less.
They have a website,
podcasts, best selling books,
a documentary on Netflix,
which is actually awesome,
if you haven't watched it.
So I encourage you to see that.
And I need my
notes for this one.
You have also been featured on
"The New York Times," "The Wall
Street Journal," "Forbes,"
"Time," ABC, NBC, BBC,
CBC, NPR--
RYAN NICODEMUS: Minimalism.
JONNY CRANMER: Yeah.
JOSHUA MILLBURN:
E-F-G-H, H-I-J-K--
RYAN NICODEMUS: I had no idea
we'd been in all those places.
JONNY CRANMER: And now,
now we have you at Google.
JOSHUA MILLBURN: Yeah,
thanks for having us.
Thanks for being here, you all.
RYAN NICODEMUS:
Thank you very much.
JONNY CRANMER: So
in true style, we
want to keep this very
discussional, questions
and answers.
To the audience, we're going
to reserve some time at the end
where we're going to
invite you guys to ask them
some questions live.
But maybe you guys
should just like
elaborate on the
introduction, tell
us a bit more about
yourselves, and then we
can get in to some questions.
JOSHUA MILLBURN:
Sure, we can just
talk about where we-- where
this whole thing started.
We're both 35 years old now,
but about seven years ago,
eight years ago,
somewhere in there, we
were kind of living the
American dream, right.
We both grew up poor
in Dayton, Ohio.
I was on food stamps and
government assistance,
and I thought the reason that
we were so unhappy growing up
is because we don't
have any money.
And so, when I turned 18, and
I know Ryan did the same thing,
I went out and got an
entry level corporate job.
And I spent the next decade just
climbing the corporate ladder.
And by age 28, I had achieved
everything I ever wanted,
the sixth figure
salary, the luxury cars,
closets full of
expensive clothes,
and the big house in the suburbs
with more toilets than people.
I really had all the
stuff to fill every corner
of my consumer driven life.
And then two things
happened to me.
My mom died and my marriage
ended, both in the same month.
And it's going to getting in two
car crashes at the same moment.
Like someone side swipes
you and all of the sudden,
another car hits you because
of it, right at the same time.
And those two events
sort of forced
me to look around and
start to question what
had become my life's focus.
And then I realized
I was so focused
on success and
achievement, and especially
like on the
accumulation of stuff.
Because in our
culture, quite often,
that's one of the-- the
sort of trophies of success,
how many things can
I amass in my life.
And I might have been
living the American dream,
but it wasn't my dream.
And sort of, in
a weird way, took
getting everything
I thought I wanted
to realize maybe everything
I ever wanted wasn't actually
what I wanted at all.
And I started refocusing.
And I discover this thing
called minimalism right
around that time.
And it was an opportunity
for me to say,
you know what, some of
the things in my life
are probably important to me.
I'm not against stuff.
I'm not against consumption now.
But at the time, I
couldn't discern really
what things add
value to my life,
and what things were just
sort of in the way, what
was essential, what
was nonessential.
Did you all know that the
average American household has
more than 300,000 items in it--
300,000.
So it's not me going
around county people stuff.
The "LA Times"
reported back in 2014.
So it might be more
threat 300,000 now,
if we're continuing
to amass more.
But I look at that--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JOSHUA MILLBURN: Do
they count every spoon?
Yeah, I guess you would
count every spoon.
But that's the weird
thing, when you
start thinking about
minimalism though,
you start thinking about
like just having no things.
And for me, that wasn't it.
When I first
discovered minimalism,
I discovered a guy
named Colin Wright.
You saw the documentary,
and he's in the documentary,
it's called "Minimalism."
And he owns 52 items.
And everything he owns
fits in his backpack.
And that actually worked
really well for him,
because he's a world traveler.
Everywhere he-- he travels
to a new country every month.
Everything he owns sort
of fits in that backpack.
And for him, owning
a kitchen table
is a liability because it
won't fit in the overhead bin.
But I looked at
that, and I'm like,
you know what, I kind of
like owning a kitchen table.
I kind of like having
a refrigerator.
But that didn't work for him.
But then I found other
minimalists as well,
people like Leo an Eva Babelto.
They live up in San Francisco.
They have six kids.
It's like a whole
minimalist family, right?
So it's like well, I don't
what to live like Colin.
I also don't want six kids.
But maybe there's a
comfortable middle.
And I realized that this
thing called minimalism,
there are different
flavors of it.
And if I wanted to
simplify my life,
I would have to figure out
what would work right for me,
what is essential for my life.
It's not like there's
a list of well,
here are the 100 items you
should own in your life,
and then you're
going to be happy.
I wish we had that list, because
I could just hand that to you
and leave, and it'd
be a lot easier.
But the truth is, the things
that add value to my life
may or may not add
value to yours.
And so I've spent the
last six, seven years
now really focused on the
things that augment my life,
as opposed to the
things that I'm just
supposed to have
because we're were
sold this meme or this template
of living the American dream.
JONNY CRANMER: Yeah,
that's very powerful.
And I guess the
first question I want
to ask you is going down the
journey for both of you, how--
well, let me phrase
it this way, what
was the easiest thing when you
started adopting minimalism
into your life, and then what
was the most difficult thing
that you encountered
trying to simplify
the stuff, the people, and the
environment around you guys?
RYAN NICODEMUS: My
whole journey began
with what Josh and I call a
packing party, where Josh first
had introduced the term
minimalism to me months
after he had been kind of
been simplifying his life.
And he told me about
what he'd been doing.
And I was like that sounds
like some common sense stuff.
Like, oh, yeah, if I don't buy
a brand new car every two years,
if I don't have this huge three
bedroom, two bathroom, 2,000
square foot home,
two living rooms.
Like, I have no
idea why I thought
I would ever need two living
rooms as a single guy.
But you know, I kind of the
saw how minimalism made sense.
Again, if I could pare down,
I could reclaim my time.
Maybe I wouldn't have to
work the 60, 70, sometimes 80
hours a week that I was putting
in to maintain this lifestyle.
So you know, I'm
at lunch with Josh,
and he's explaining this to me.
And I look up at him,
and I'm like this
sounds pretty awesome.
Like, OK, I want
to be a minimalist.
I'm in.
Now what?
I didn't really
know where to start.
And I don't want to spend
several months simplifying
like Josh.
That was great for him.
He's always been a little
bit more patient than me.
But I needed faster results.
So we came up with this idea
to pack all my belongings
as if I were moving.
And then I would unpack only the
items I needed over the next 21
days, to really get an
idea of what I was using
and what was adding value.
So Josh came over
to literally help
me box up everything, my
clothes, kitchenware, towels,
TVs, furniture.
I mean, literally
everything we packed up.
And you can imagine
that first night.
I unpacked my toothbrush
and some toiletries,
and some clothes for work the
next day, bed and bed sheets.
And as time went on, I just
was unpacking less and less.
So after three weeks, I'm
standing in my second living
room looking at these boxes,
just like stacked halfway
to my 12 foot ceiling,
but still had about 80%
of my stuff sitting there.
And that for me was like, that
was the first huge light bulb
moment for me.
Like, here are all
these things I brought
into my life to make me happy.
And hardly any of
it is doing its job.
So I decided to donate
and sell all of it.
Now there's a couple exceptions.
Like, I'm a snowboarder.
I hung on to some winter items.
I hung on to my snowboard
that maybe I hadn't
used in those three weeks.
But for all intents
and purposes,
I donated and sold everything.
And I'll tell you, it was easy
for me when it came to close.
Like, you go to that--
I would go to that
drawer or box that
had 20 yardworking or
painting T-shirts, like--
and I'm not an artist.
I mean, painting like, painting
the living room or something.
And I'm like looking
at myself like, wow,
like here are all these shirts
I've amassed over my life,
whether it was some
kind of corporate event,
they're handing
out free T-shirts,
or I'm at a baseball game and
I catch a T-shirt that shot out
of a cannon.
I had all the T-shirts
that I never wore,
but I had them because I
wanted to hold on to them, just
in case.
JONNY CRANMER: Sounds
like something we
do at Google a lot.
A lot of free
T-shirts given out.
RYAN NICODEMUS: So yeah,
that was probably the easiest
stuff to get rid of.
But I'll tell you, some
stuff I didn't realize
would be so hard.
Like I remember, Josh came
over after the three weeks,
and he's helping me
separate these things
into different piles.
And I remember watching him
take this like box of mugs,
in he's putting it
in the donation pile.
I'm like what are you
doing, man, I drink coffee.
Why are you getting
rid of all those mugs.
And he opens up it up, and
he's like, dude, there's
like 30 coffee mugs in here.
How many cups of
coffee can you drink?
And I'm like, well, you
know, I have guests over,
and what if 25 of those break.
Like, what-- I'm not going
to have those backups.
And he pulls out a mug and
it says world's number one
granddad on it or something.
Like, I have no idea,
probably bought it
for a dollar somewhere, thinking
it was funny, never used it.
And I'm like, yeah,
you're right, I have not--
I have not used that in
years, and I'm probably
not going to use that in
the next couple of years.
But it was just kind of
amazing that the coffee mugs
was like the first
thing that I was like,
whoa, can't rid of my
coffee mugs, I drink coffee.
But then certainly
going into other things,
like sentimental items.
That was really,
really difficult.
I remember I was kind of
going through some stuff.
Josh had left.
And I came across this shoebox.
It was like all my high school--
you know, my high school
memories were in this box.
And I open it up and there's
some letters that my mom had
written me in high school,
and a pictures of me
in my junior prom and
senior prom dates.
The shot glass they
gave us as the prom gift
at the high school.
I have no idea what
they were thinking.
But I came across
all these memories,
and I was like, well,
you're a minimalist now,
you can't hold on to this.
You got to get rid of it.
And I'm like walking to the
trashcan, and I'm like, no,
I can't.
I'm just going to
put this one off.
I'm going to wait
and was starting
to bargain with myself.
And eventually,
what I kind of did
is I was like I'm going
to choose one thing out
of this box, and I'm
going to get rid of it
and just see how I
feel in the morning.
So I picked out a
letter that my mom
had written me in high school.
Just to kind of preface it
a little bit, of my parents
got divorced when I
was seven years old.
My mom had a lot of drug
and alcohol problems.
And she would just write
me some letters that
were really encouraging
during high school, and just
some intimate moments
that her and I shared.
And at the end of the day, I
picked one of those letters,
and before I even
read it, I sort of
like started getting
this emotion,
this emotion was being invoked.
And I read the letter, and after
I got done reading the letter,
it gave me a completely
different feeling.
It was so weird.
Like the thought of
the letter gave me
a different feeling than
actually reading the letter.
So I laid it on the table,
I took my camera phone,
and I took a picture of
it, zoomed in and made
sure I could still
read it if I really
wanted to go back and read it.
And I threw it away
in the trash can.
I didn't even realize
it was in the trash can
until like the
next night or even
the night after that when I
went to go take out the trash
and there it was,
sitting on top.
And I'm like, oh,
yeah, that letter.
It wasn't that
hard to let go of.
So I did the same thing with
a few other items in the box,
just took some pictures
of it, and then
ended up just tossing it.
And I haven't missed it since.
I'm sure-- I had someone tweet
me the other day, because we
were talking about this on
the podcast the other day.
And someone tweeted
me and they're
like someone asked me for my
prom photo of high school,
and like I threw it away,
I wish I had had it.
And I'm like, , OK I don't
think everyone should hang
on to every single
picture they ever have.
JOSHUA MILLBURN: I think it's--
the weird thing is, the reason
we have a lot of those 300,000
items, whatever it might be is,
is those three words that Ryan
mentioned, just in case.
Like we go to get rid of
something, and you're like,
I should hold on to
this just in case
I need it someday in some
nonexistent hypothetical
future.
And so we amass
these sort of hoards,
and when the first
junk drawer fills up,
we allocate a
second junk drawer.
And that one fills up,
we would find the cabinet
or cupboard or something.
And we need more and more space.
And so we don't give
ourselves permission
to let go of these things.
And I found that I was
holding on to so many things
just in case, weather it
was a sentimental item,
and I didn't have a plan
to do anything with it.
I was sort of a well
organized hoarder.
I wasn't a candidate for
the TV show, "Hoarders."
There were no dead cats
in my freezer or anything.
But I owned a lot of stuff.
So I had an ordinal system of
bins and boxes in my basement.
And I used to weigh 80
pounds more than I weigh now.
And so I had a lot of
like double XL shirts.
That was my plan, in case--
just in case I gained
80 pounds back,
I'll have these out of date
clothes to wear some day.
And when you start
saying things out loud,
you realize how ridiculous
many of the things that we're
holding on to are.
But I just want to be
clear, don't get me wrong,
there are some things that
add immense value to my life.
In fact, it's the weird
paradox of minimalism.
I get far more
value from the items
that I have now then if
they were watered down
by hundreds of
thousands of items.
I think if you walk into my
home today, you don't walk in,
and say, oh, my god,
this guy's a minimalist.
You probably just say,
wow, they're tidy.
And it's because I don't
own a lot of stuff.
But everything I own
now, it serves a purpose,
or it brings me joy.
Everything else
is out of the way.
RYAN NICODEMUS: You
know, it's funny,
we were on-- we were doing a
live cast a couple months ago,
and I don't know what platform
we were on, but someone--
JOSHUA MILLBURN:
Google Hangouts.
RYAN NICODEMUS: Yes,
I think that's what
it was, actually, yes.
And someone in the
comments section,
they were like, you know, it
sounds like, I don't know what
the big deal is, guys, it
doesn't sound like you gave up
anything that was important.
And Josh was like,
that's exactly it.
We didn't give up
anything that's import.
Everything we have in our lives
right now, it is important.
And I think that's when
minimalism is really about.
It's about determining what
is important in one's life.
And that is different
for everyone.
JONNY CRANMER: So I wanted
to dig a bit deeper on that,
because it's a fascinating
journey that you've
gone through.
And I think there's two
things I'm hearing here.
It's like a physical
let go of possessions
and a de-cluttering.
And then there's a
psychological benefit.
But they both kind of work
in tandem with each other.
How did you feel when you both
went through this process?
What were the
outcomes, and what made
you want to continue doing it?
Because obviously,
the effects were good,
whether it was like
mental, you felt better,
productivity went up.
So give us some
of those examples
of why you loved it so much.
JOSHUA MILLBURN: I think
the material possessions
are our physical manifestation
of what's going on inside.
At least they were for me.
Like, so I had all of
this external clutter.
It was really a result of
a lot of internal clutter.
You can call it mental
clutter, emotional clutter,
spiritual clutter,
financial clutter, whatever
that internal clutter is.
It started with the stuff.
But I also think that
minimalism isn't just
about getting rid of
your stuff either.
I think anyone in here
today, tonight you
could just go home,
and rent a dumpster,
and throw all your crap in
it and be utterly miserable.
You just come home
to an empty house
and sulk after removing
all your pacifiers.
And that's because the
consumption isn't the problem.
Compulsory consumption
is the problem.
I feel like I must do this.
I have to accumulate
more, more, more, more.
And so, once I started dealing
with what was going on outside,
I was able to look
inward and start dealing
with what was going on inside.
And figured out, you know
what-- it started for me
with the finances.
Because I made really good
money in the corporate world.
A couple hundred thousand
dollars in Dayton, Ohio is--
I mean, King of the
Hill kind of thing.
I know that's probably
not impressive here.
Ryan, this is what
it feels like to have
the lowest IQ in a room.
RYAN NICODEMUS: And
also stupid enough.
JOSHUA MILLBURN: Also the
smallest bank account.
But I realized that I started
because of the financial thing.
I made good money but
spent even better money.
And so I had massive
amounts of debt.
Sixty years worth of debt,
half a million dollars,
if you count my mortgage.
And so I'm like, if I regain
control of my expenses,
then I won't have
this burden on me,
I won't have this huge anchor,
and I won't necessarily
be tethered to this career,
that I'm starting to figure out
doesn't aline with my values.
But from there, I uncovered
all these other benefits,
whether it was my health
or my relationships.
I think many of
our relationships--
we were talking about this when
we had lunch a couple months
ago--
a lot of our relationships,
especially growing up,
they're birthed out of
proximity and convenience.
And so we live in the
same neighborhood,
we work in the same office, or
we went to the same high school
together, whatever it may be.
And there's nothing inherently
wrong with those people.
But it also might mean that
we don't share similar values.
And I found in my
life, in particular,
I was spending 90% of
the time, of my time,
with people who didn't
share the same values as me.
They were good people.
They just didn't
have the same values.
And I forsook the most important
relationships in my life.
It's the reason
my marriage ended.
It's the reason I became distant
from a lot of my other friends,
is because I was so
focused on networking,
and spending time
with executives,
and stuff like that.
And so, by dealing
with that stuff first,
I was able to identify
what the benefits were
for me, whether it was finances,
or health, or relationships,
or contributing to my community.
And it was a more--
I won't say balanced life, but
it was a more meaningful life.
JONNY CRANMER: Yeah, yeah.
RYAN NICODEMUS: I think for
me, like the more revelation--
some more of the
revelation moments
I had facing my hoard of stuff
after that packing party,
I just kind of looked at this
heap of tens of thousands
of dollars worth of stuff.
And was forced to think
about the narrative
that I was playing
out in my head.
And what I was
telling myself was,
I make really good money
in the corporate world,
I'm saving for retirement.
I was putting away whatever
they would match, like 1%
or whatever we were at,
or something, you know.
But then I really
started to think about,
like my goal was
to retire early.
And I certainly wasn't going
to do that with the money
that I was taking
out of the paycheck.
And everything else that I had
in that room-- not everything
else, but a lot of that
stuff I had in the room,
I put on credit cards.
And I was thinking,
wow, if I actually
would have saved
some of this money,
instead of going out and trying
to buy the latest gadget,
or trying to go on
the coolest vacation,
or going out and racking
up $300 bar tabs,
maybe I could
actually focus on what
I want my priorities to be.
And I think the biggest
thing that minimalism really
helped me do, is to get clear
on what my priorities were
and what I wanted them to be.
Because for the
longest time, if you
were to ask my 25 or
26-year-old self, like, hey,
Ryan, what are your priorities,
I would have said my health.
If I'm not healthy,
I'm not happy.
My relationships--
you know, my mom, she
lived a half hour away.
I might have seen her six
or seven times a year.
Health wise, I was eating
out fast food a lot.
Or I would say,
oh, you know, I'm
working on the big
passion project
that I've been putting
off for two years.
That's my priority.
And what I realized is
I gave my priorities
a lot of lip service.
And what I was able to do is
to actually make my priorities
my actual priorities.
And that's what
our priorities are.
It's not what we say they are.
It's what we actually
do with our time.
JONNY CRANMER: Yeah.
Before we go done that
a little bit more,
I think one thing I found
fascinating that came out
the documentary is that if
you adopt the principlism--
principles, sorry-- of
minimalism, it can--
JOSHUA MILLBURN: I like
that-- principlism.
JONNY CRANMER: Where
did that word come from?
Principlisms,
minimalisms together.
JOSHUA MILLBURN: Someone's
registering that URL
in the crowd right now.
JONNY CRANMER: New
title for a book
So you get beneficial
effects for you
as a person, probably
the people around you.
But there's another
ripple effect that I felt,
that I noticed from
the documentary, which
is it's actually beneficial
to the environment.
It's beneficial to
wider groups of people.
Because the consumerism
that we're so sucked into,
and that we buy and hoard,
it has larger ripple effects,
right?
JOSHUA MILLBURN: Yeah.
JONNY CRANMER: So,
in essence, you're
doing a good thing for
yourself, but you're
also having this wider effect.
JOSHUA MILLBURN: It sounds
overly simplistic to say this,
but for whatever reason, I
didn't realize it at the time,
if you consume less,
you produce less waste.
And I mean, it wasn't like--
I didn't approach minimalism
because I was like,
I'm going to save
the environment,
although it was a really
good benefit to realize,
you know what, if I
consume 90% less stuff,
I'm going to produce
90% less waste.
It has that kind
of ripple effect.
And so figuring out that there
are these additional benefits,
once you start going
down that rabbit hole.
People at work started coming
up to me, saying things like,
you seem less stressed,
what's going on in your life.
You seem so much calmer.
Why are you being
so nice lately.
Because I never jumped
up and said, look at me,
I'm becoming a minimalist,
and you need to as well.
And even now, Ryan and
I aren't proselytizing.
I'm not trying to convert
anyone in here to minimalism.
We're just sharing
something that's
worked really well for us.
We've seen it work really well
for thousands of other people.
And we want to
build to share that,
in hopes that maybe you
can get a few ingredients
from our recipe, tease
those out, and find a way
to maybe simplify a little bit,
if that's what you want to do.
JONNY CRANMER: Yeah, so to bring
Google into the conversation
a little bit.
I know when we
sat down at lunch,
we talked a little bit
about the digital influences
we have in our lives
that clutter it
rather than streamline it.
Let's put Google in
that bucket, let's
put Facebook,
Instagram, et cetera.
Where do you see Google's
position in the world,
as you view it
through minimalism?
Do you think that we produce
services and products that
are generally good for people?
Or do you think that
in areas we clutter?
JONNY CRANMER:
Yeah, I don't think
either one's mutually exclusive.
I mean, if you look at the
tools that we have in our lives.
If I have-- well,
here's a good example,
because Ryan almost cut his
thumb off the other day.
If you have a knife, you're
cutting onions with it,
and it's a useful tool.
But you can use that knife
to do great harm as well.
And so if I look at the tools
that we have in our lives,
whether it is
Gmail, which I use,
obviously use Google
as a search engine.
If I look at those
tools in our lives
how am I using these tools, and
am I being intentional with it.
And I think there are
some steps that we
can take to sort of mitigate
the impulse, as well.
There's an app I've
been using my phone,
called Moment, which sort of
tracks how much screen time I'm
spending on my phone.
The interesting
thing about that,
as soon as I put
that up on my phone,
I realized that just
by the sheer fact
that I'm tracking it, I'm
using my phone differently.
Because I know I'm being
watched all of the sudden.
Even thought it's just me
watching myself in a way,
and I'm trying to improve that.
And so my screen time
with down drastically.
And I think there are
other things we can do.
We can remove apps
we're not using,
or apps we don't want to use.
We can take temporary
of, sabbaticals.
We have weekends
for a reason, right?
But do we do weekends
away from social media?
Do we have a day that this sort
of our digital sabbath day,
as well.
I have a good friend who
lives in Los Angeles, who
every Friday night, he
shuts off his computer
and doesn't open it back
up until Sunday morning.
And so realizing that you
can set up these routines
in your life-- in fact, we were
just having this conversation
on the way over here,
about why did Google--
there were all these other
search engines at one point,
right?
There was Dogpile, and--
RYAN NICODEMUS: Ask Jeeves.
JOSHUA MILLBURN: And Yahoo,
and all these other places.
What made Google
really stand out?
And I mean, to me
that was the sort
of the epitome of minimalism.
If you want to--
if you sort of did
a split screen,
you went to Yahoo on one
page, you went to Google
on the other, and
you saw one of them
was cluttered with all this
additional information,
and one was functionally
this, right?
I mean, it was one line,
you type something in there
with I'm feeling lucky, and
what was the other thing that
comes up, the advance search
thing, and that was it.
I mean, that was
minimalism brought
to the web search for the
first time in an elegant way.
And what that
minimalism allowed then
was also to create the
best search engine as well.
I mean, the reason everyone
goes to Google now, part of it
has to with the
simplicity of it.
But the other part is you think
you're going to get the best
results from that experience.
And so, it if by stripping
everything else down
you're able to really focus
on what you're core competency
is, then that I found that
creates a better experience,
not just for the user,
but for the company,
and everything else.
JONNY CRANMER: Yeah,
it's interesting
when you put it that way,
because I would agree
with you, that
Google probably did
have it's success by being
very simple with that homepage.
So that's an interesting point.
To the people that are
hear, listening, what would
you say to them, if they're
interested by minimalism,
as a sort of like
beginner's guide
to start exploring how
they could bring it
into their lives.
RYAN NICODEMUS: Well,
there's a few ways to start.
You could have a packing party.
It might be a little
unreasonable or too extreme
for a family of six or
eight, or something.
JONNY CRANMER: What is the
game that you guys invented?
I read about this.
RYAN NICODEMUS: Yeah, so this
is a little more approachable.
We have something called
the 30 day minimalism game.
And de-cluttering, it
can be boring sometimes.
So Josh I decided to
make it fun by adding
a little friendly competition.
So you find a friend,
or a family member,
or a coworker, who wants
to get rid of stuff.
And you both agree
to play this game.
And you start on the
first day of the month.
So you know, July is
just around the corner.
You could start on July 1st.
You both agree to get rid of
one thing on the first day
the month.
And then on the second
day of the month,
you get rid of two things.
And then on the third day
of the month, three things.
And then on the fourth day--
OK, so forth and so on.
You probably get how it works.
So it starts off
really, really easy,
up until you get to like day
19, you get rid of 19 things.
And then the next
day, on day 20,
you're like oh, crap, I got
to get rid of 20 things today.
And it's funny, because
my partner, Mariah, and I,
we played this not too long ago.
And even as me being
one of the minimalists,
we still were able to make
it through the whole month.
And if you do, you get
rid of about 500 items.
So, you know, you bet
something real silly,
like maybe a dinner,
or something small,
or someone has to cook dinner.
JOSHUA MILLBURN: This is Google,
you can bet a million dollars.
RYAN NICODEMUS: You can
bet a million dollars.
JOSHUA MILLBURN: Raise
the stakes, Nicodemus.
RYAN NICODEMUS: What
Mariah did is she--
no, this is pretty good.
So Mariah was
playing with a friend
of hers in Fargo, North Dakota.
And the loser had to
basically karaoke a song
that the other person,
that the winner picked out.
So they both ended up
making it through the month.
But in that case, they both
won, because they both had
gotten rid of about 500 items.
JOSHUA MILLBURN: Yeah,
I think the other way--
that's a very
practical, how-to step.
But the other side
of simplify our lives
is understanding
the why to side.
What's the purpose?
And so for me the really
important question early on
was how might your life
be better with less?
And I think by
answering that question,
you're able to identify the
benefits of minimalism for you.
And I think they're
different for everyone.
The benefits for--
I've got a four-year-old now.
The benefits for a
four-year-old are
going to be so
considerably different
from the benefits for you,
versus anyone else in the room.
For some people's, it's
health, its finances,
reclaiming your
time, your attention.
And you have to figure out what
those benefits are for you.
Because that's going to give you
really the leverage you need.
I think we all instinctually
know how to de-clutter.
You're not going to see me and
Ryan write something like here
are the 67 ways for
you to de-clutter
your closet this weekend.
Because we all know
how to do that.
The question is why
are we doing it.
And once you understand that,
I think you have the leverage
you need to move forward.
JONNY CRANMER: Yeah,
that brings up a memory.
When I was listening to your
podcast, I think the last one,
you had Q&A. It was
an eight-year-old that
came on, and asked you how do
I apply minimalism to my life.
JOSHUA MILLBURN: Yeah
JONNY CRANMER: Which is a-- it's
kind of crazy thing to think
about, because--
you answered it well, like it
can be applied to everyone,
but for a kid to ask you,
it's kind of crazy thing.
JOSHUA MILLBURN: Yeah.
RYAN NICODEMUS: Yeah, we
had a five-year-old girl
at our last event in San Diego.
And her parents were like this
is our five-year-old daughter.
She's a big fan of you guys.
She came up and she's like
I donated some of my clothes
yesterday.
I was just like she is so
much further ahead than me.
That is amazing that she
can get into that mindset.
And for her, I
don't think it was
about not owning a lot of toys.
It was the fact that--
and through her parents--
she is getting these principles,
especially the principle
of giving.
I mean, giving is living.
When I look at my
values and beliefs,
contribution is way up there.
And the fact that
she's five years old,
and she can use this
thing called minimalism
to help her contribute
more, beyond herself,
in a meaningful way.
I think that's pretty awesome.
JONNY CRANMER:
Yeah, so a bit more
of a hard hitting question,
by an interesting one.
Some of the folks
thought this one up.
The idea of
de-cluttering and getting
rid of your
possessions, some people
would call that, perhaps,
a movement for the elite,
for people that have
money and can do that.
What about those that don't have
anything, and arguably already
live a minimalist life?
How do you respond to that?
And then, can the
same principles
be applied to their
life, although they
don't have as much, to
make them feel they're
living a more intentional life.
JOSHUA MILLBURN:
And the question
is really about privilege.
And I think it's an important
question, especially
in today's environment,
because we're
seeing different
classes of people,
where you have this
divide that's happening.
And especially in
the United States,
where you have
socio-economic classes.
And I say that word
in vocal quotes.
I grew up really
poor, and realized
that maybe we're not happy,
because we need more money.
And so when I started
climbing the corporate ladder,
I'm like wait a minute, $50,000
year isn't making me happy.
I need to adjust for inflation.
And so maybe it's
$75,000 a year.
Maybe it's six figures, or maybe
it owning a bunch of stuff.
Maybe that's going
to make me happy.
And in time, what
I realized is we
weren't discontent when we
were growing up just because
of money.
I mean, money will
buy you certain levels
of comfort and certain things
that you need, for sure.
But beyond basic
needs, the correlation
between happiness
and money falls off
with the abruptness
of a cliff, right?
And so, what I realized is that
I was just starting to
make the same bad decisions
we made before I was 18.
But money enabled me to
make even worse decisions,
go into debt with
those decisions.
And so I had to
be really careful.
And in a weird way, I have a
different kind of privilege.
I have the privilege of
seeing both sides of it.
I had the privilege of growing
up poor and being in poverty,
like true poverty.
Electricity being turned off
in the winter kind of poverty.
And I saw that.
And I contrast that
with what's going on,
or what went on in my
'20s, where I ostensibly
had it all, and was still
discontented by that.
And I think weather I was
poor, or when I was wealthy,
or when I'm
somewhere in between,
I find that no matter where I am
on the soico-economic spectrum,
I benefit from living a
more intentional life.
In fact, I know
now, in retrospect,
looking back 30
years in the past,
I would have benefited
a lot more from being
more intentional, especially
when we had fewer resources.
If you don't have
that many resources,
you want to be very
deliberate with how
you use those resources.
And it's not just
money, by the way.
Money is one resource.
It's also a renewable resource.
It's your time,
it's your attention.
These are resources, these are
things that we can't get back.
And so the one thing that's
been really encouraging,
and one of the reasons
we go out on tour now,
it's so we can listen to people.
And we have factory
workers, and we have
CEOs show up at the same event.
And they're asking
the same questions.
I mean, the questions
manifest differently depending
where you are on the
socio-economic spectrum.
But they're really saying I feel
like my life's out of control,
and how do I regain
control of that life.
Because we all, at
the end of the day,
we want to figure out how to
live a more meaningful life.
No matter what we're doing
with our time and resources,
that's really what we're
trying to accomplish.
And so, minimalism's
just a way for us
to be more deliberate with
the resources we have.
RYAN NICODEMUS: I'll tell you
one of my favorite experiences
on tour.
We went on a 100
city tour in 2014.
And we were in Belfast, and
this gentleman came up to me.
And at the time, because
we weren't as popular
as we are now, I guess.
But we could literally
just be like, hey,
we're going to be at this coffee
shop, show up if you want to.
And like 20 people, 30
people would show up.
We didn't have to
charge for tickets.
Now if we did that, there'd
be 600 people showing up
at a coffee shop, and the owner
would probably be mad at us
for having--
what do they call that--
JOSHUA MILLBURN: A flash mob.
RYAN NICODEMUS: A flash mob.
A minimalist flash mob
show up at the coffee shop.
But he comes up to me, and he's
like, you know, my name's Dee,
and I just want to
tell you, man, he's
like thank you so much
for doing what you do.
He's like, I am--
I'm a fighter.
And I'm like, yeah,
man, me too, we're
all fighting the good fight.
And he's like, no, no, like
I box, like I'm a fighter.
And I'm like, oh, wow, cool man.
JOSHUA MILLBURN: Are
you threatening me?
RYAN NICODEMUS: Yeah, and I'm
look oh, cool, how is that?
And he's like, I love it,
man, I absolutely love it.
He was like now I'm
the guy though--
and if I could do
a Belfast accent,
I would totally do his
part in that accent,
but I wouldn't do it no justice.
JOSHUA MILLBURN:
You're Belfast accent?
JONNY CRANMER: I was
going to jump in,
but I'm not going to do it.
He looked at me and I was
like, no, it's not happening.
RYAN NICODEMUS:
So he's telling me
about how he loves what he does
and he was saying, like now,
I'm the fighter that
they put into the ring
to get beat up on,
like when there's
a well-known fighter that has an
exhibition match or something,
I'm the one that they put in
the ring to get beat up on.
He's like, but I
absolutely love it.
And he's like, I also
train other fighters
and I'm able to transfer some
of my knowledge to other people.
He's like but I
am dirt poor, man.
He goes, like, I
literally some months,
I'll sleep on my
friend's couch, and just
like really telling me how he
doesn't have a lot of money.
But he's like I just want to say
thank you for helping me to not
feel like a loser.
For all intents and
purposes, this guy
is living a starving
artist life.
And the fact that we
can give him permission,
I guess is maybe a
way to look at it,
for him to do what he loves
without worrying about what
his friends think about him,
how much money he makes,
or maybe his parents are giving
him a hard time because he
doesn't make a lot of money.
But the fact that
we can encourage
him to do what he loves.
I mean, that's what I
really love about this.
We had a girl in Adelaide
who came up to us.
She was in line, and
she was like, you
know, it wasn't until I
read your book, "Everything
that Remains," I didn't
realize the bad decisions I
was making with my life.
She was like I've been
homeless for years.
She's like but over the
last three or four months,
I've been able to
make better decisions
through this inspiration
that you've given me.
And she's like I have
a steady job now.
I've been able to hold
a home for a few months.
And stories like that, to
me, kind of automatically--
I don't want to say shuts down
the argument of privilege,
because I think it's something
that is a very important thing
to talk about.
But it definitely shows how
minimalism, it does really,
really apply to anyone on
the socio-economic scale.
JONNY CRANMER: It
sounds like you can
just-- it enables people,
gives them more focus
where they need to be focusing.
And when they focus
in the right areas,
you just get that
natural energy,
because you're being with
who you want to be with,
you're doing what
you want to do.
And that becomes your
drive and you're singly
going towards that.
RYAN NICODEMUS: I
just think it helps
people ask better questions,
is what I was going to say.
JOSHUA MILLBURN:
That word, focus,
I think is an important one.
How many of you
all are busy today?
Right?
So your life's out
of control, right?
No, I'm joking, halfway.
But I used to wear this term
busy as a badge of honor,
right?
Hey, you want to grab
coffee tomorrow morning?
Can't, I'm so busy.
What's going on next week?
I'd love to meet, I'm
just so busy right now.
And like, it was this--
it was a catch-all excuse.
But really, for me
at least, it meant
that, man, I don't
really, I don't have
control of what's going on.
And for me now, busy
is like the worst
four letter word there is,
because it means that I'm not
able to control my days.
And so it probably
doesn't look very
good on a graph, like I don't do
nearly as much as I used to do.
But I get a lot more meaningful
work done now I feel like.
Because I'm not
busy, I'm focused.
And so, in fact, anytime, when
we're on the road or something,
and someone's like, oh,
you guys sure are busy.
I'm like, no, we're focused.
But the only way to
get there is I've
had to get good at saying no
over the last six or seven
years.
And I'm far from perfect.
And I say yes to the
wrong things all the time.
But I'm much better now.
Because I'm so much
better at saying no,
I can't do that, because
here's what I'm saying yes to.
It's not just no, no, no, it's
saying yes to the right things.
Because the opposite
used to be true.
I'd say yes to anything
that came along.
And then by default, I had
to say no to the things that
were actually important to me.
JONNY CRANMER: I think I
remember when we had lunch,
maybe both of you
have this principle,
that you don't have
tasks in your day.
Is that accurate?
JOSHUA MILLBURN: Yeah,
for the most part.
I mean, there are
always sort of--
I don't have a to-do list.
JONNY CRANMER: Or schedule.
JOSHUA MILLBURN: We
definitely have a calendar.
In fact, we use
Google calendars.
And in fact, one of the things--
you can call it a productivity
hack or whatever, for me.
But like I said, I'm
probably far less productive
now on the sense of just
checking things off a list.
But we share the calendar with
everyone who's on our team.
And you'll know, nope, anytime
before 2:00 PM, usually,
when we're at home, you
can't book anything with me,
because I'm going to spend
that time writing, or reading,
or exercising.
I've got a really bad back,
so I'm doing physical therapy.
So it's that, and so I
find ways to block off
large chunks of time that are
meaningful, like deep work
time, so that I am
living that best life,
and I can say yes to the
most important things
during that block.
And it gives me less, far
fewer hours to say yes
to other things,
but I still have
other time that I can say yes.
But yeah, you're not going
to see back, to back,
to back meetings
for me or anything.
JONNY CRANMER:
And so, how do you
guys apply that to what
you're doing nowadays.
Because the amount of
TV networks I read out
at the beginning, that you've
been on, applies to everything
you're doing today.
You run a website,
you have a podcast,
you have a documentary
on Netflix.
You write books,
you write essays,
you have courses for
people, you're here
at Talks for Google.
You're on a tour at the moment.
I wouldn't necessarily
call that minimalist.
But you guys are driving it, and
it seems to be working for you.
So how do you explain that?
I mean, is it the focus the
helps you drive all that stuff?
RYAN NICODEMUS:
Absolutely, you know--
first off, I'll say
when you call yourselves
the minimalists, everything you
do becomes steeped in irony.
I mean, we don't sell a very
minimalist amount of books.
You should see the
crowds that show up.
They're not a very
minimalist amount of people.
Yes, we don't have a
very minimalist amount
of tour stops.
But at the end of
the day, if you
were to look at the terminus
of what a minimalist
or what a lot of people
think a minimalist is,
would be a monk in a monastery
somewhere, in a monestery
somewhere, just
meditating all day long,
owning five possessions.
Well, if we did that,
we wouldn't really
be able to help many
people, would we?
So, for us, it's not about--
it's not about having nothing.
It's certainly not
about deprivation.
Like I said earlier,
we have a lot
of important things
in our lives.
In fact, everything
we have is important.
It adds value, or brings us
joy, or serves a purpose.
And all the things
that you listed,
it's not like we
started just, oh, we're
going to start the
minimalist.com,
and we got to write three books,
we got to start a podcast,
we got that documentary that's
going to come out in 2016.
Oh, by the way, we've
got to plan these tours.
And then, we gotta
make sure we're
on all these major networks.
I mean, all of this has
happened very organically.
I mean, even with
the documentary--
I remember-- our
director's up there, Matt.
He came with us on tour in 2014.
And he just filmed
a bunch of stuff.
And we had no idea what
was going to become of it.
We had very low expectations.
But we have very high standards.
And what ended up
happening was the result
that you see now, with
"Minimalism," the documentary,
about the important things.
But it certainly
didn't start off
with we're going to
have Netflix deals,
we're going to be in theaters.
It was just Matt, who is
a minimalist himself, just
wanted to join us
to work on something
he was passionate about.
And then it turned
into something amazing.
And that's kind
of a short version
of what Josh and I've done over
the last six or seven years.
It's things that--
what Josh said earlier.
It's things that we're
able to put on our plate
because we keep our plate
so clear of distractions,
that were able to
take on these things.
And yes, over the last
six or seven years,
we have had some
amazing things happen.
And we have had a
lot of things happen.
But I kind of look at it
as something we have like
layered on top of each other.
When we first started, it
was the blog and essays.
And then I started getting
a bunch of emails about,
hey, can you--
2,000 word emails
on a regular basis.
Like, hey, can how help me
fix all my life problems?
And I'm like, god, I
wish I could somehow
help people to do this.
I can't answer every
2,000 word email I get.
So I started a little mentoring,
a little coaching business.
And Josh was getting a lot
of questions on writing.
So he started a writing class.
And then from there, we wrote
"Minimalism," our first book.
And at the end of the day,
it was, again, layered on.
We would we would
keep our plates clear,
say yes to the things
that we had time for,
the things that
we had space for.
And we've continued that
approach throughout.
And yes, looking back,
it sounds like so much.
But it's been very intentional.
And the reason why we've
been able to do so much
is because we have,
again, been able to say
no to a lot of things so we
can say yes to these very
big, important things.
JONNY CRANMER: Yeah, that's
inspiring stuff to hear.
I think we're probably
approaching some time
to give the audience
some questions.
JOSHUA MILLBURN: Great.
JONNY CRANMER: But
before we hand that over,
the final question
I have for you,
and somewhat you've answered
it, but if you could just
pinpoint one thing.
Through the journey you've both
been through in minimalism,
and will continue
to have, what has
been the most impactful
thing that minimalism
has brought to your life.
JOSHUA MILLBURN: I think
for me, and it was actually
the hardest thing to get
rid of, was my identity.
When you meet someone,
what's the first question
that they ask you?
AUDIENCE: What do you do?
JOSHUA MILLBURN: What do you do?
Right?
And I think it's life's
most dangerous question.
I don't think people
like have a bad intent
behind that question, obviously.
It just becomes part of
our everyday tete-a-tete.
You meet someone,
what do you do.
And it's a really broad question
when you think about it.
What do you mean what do I do?
I drink water.
I go to concerts.
I enjoy going to the
beach and surfing.
What we mean what do I do?
Oh, I mean, where you work,
how much money do you earn,
so I can compare you to me
on the socio-economic ladder.
Now if we posit the
question that way,
you sound like a total jerk.
And so instead, we
just say what you do.
And then we recite the
title on our business card.
Sometimes that's impressive.
I used to have an
impressive job title.
I was director of operations
for 150 retail stores, which
is really ironic with the
whole minimalism thing.
And so I managed a
bunch of retail stores.
And so I would say,
here's what I do,
and I'd say what do you do.
But I found that I was so much
more than just that job title.
There's nothing wrong
with having a job.
We all have to pay
the bills and find
ways to do that in a way
that aligns with the person
we want to be.
But at the same time, I
was so much more than that.
So I had to untether from
what that identity was.
And so when people start asking
that question, what do you do,
I'd say I'm really
passionate about writing.
I didn't say I was a writer.
Because then you get the
accusatory questions.
What have you written,
who's your publisher, who's
your agent?
It's like, well, no one yet.
But I really like writing.
And so I would say I'm really
passionate about writing
and I'd flip the
question around,
and I'd say what are
you passionate about?
Sometimes you get the
deer in headlights
look, because they're ready
to recite that business
card to you.
And other times, it just
changes the direction
of the conversation.
The trajectory all of the
sudden was like, well, I'm
passionate about
skiing, or snowboarding,
I really like doing this.
And then we end up having much
more meaningful conversations.
I did that experiment for
over the course of a year.
I found that I was
able to really untether
from here's what I do,
and that means that's who
I am as an individual.
JONNY CRANMER: Yeah,
that's powerful.
RYAN NICODEMUS: For
me, it's freedom.
I truly feel free.
And what I mean
by that is I just
became debt free for the
first time a couple years ago.
JONNY CRANMER: Congratulations.
RYAN NICODEMUS: Thanks,
thank you very much.
I mean, that is, to me,
that's a new American dream,
is having zero debt.
Because we have so much
freedom in this country.
I mean, an 18-year-old
can graduate high school
and sign up for six figures
worth of student loans.
It just blows my mind,
the freedom that we have.
And I'm totally ripping
this off from "Spider Man,"
but with that freedom,
comes great responsibility.
And we have to make decisions
with all the rope that
is given to us.
So now-- this whole
thing started with I just
wanted to pay off some debt.
I wanted to l get rid
of my fancy car I had,
get rid of that debt payment.
I wanted to get rid of my home,
that debt payment I had there.
I just wanted to have a life
to where I could be a barista
and live off of
$25-$30,000 a year.
If everything right
now, if the rug
was like slipped out
from underneath of us,
internet blew up, we
couldn't sell books online,
or we couldn't tour
anymore, whatever.
Let's just say
everything hit the fan.
I could turn my life
around on a dime right now.
I'd have to move apartments.
My rent's a little
high for someone
who makes $30,000 a
year, or $25,000 a year.
But I have no lease.
And I can do that in a second.
And that to me, that
is true freedom.
And that is why I
think "Minimalism" is
so important for many people.
It kind of helps
them to, I guess,
put a template together on
what looks free for them.
And then work towards that.
JONNY CRANMER:
Powerful, very powerful.
So we'll turn it
back to the audience,
if anyone has any questions.
I think that we
have to use this.
I think we tap it and throw it.
RYAN NICODEMUS: Tap it?
Did I do it right?
Nice.
AUDIENCE: 1-1-2-1-2?
First I have to get one
protest out of the way.
I think it should be fine
to have one box with letters
that you got from your mother.
There's something
about the paper.
And it wouldn't make
you less of minimalist.
Just kind of a thought there.
RYAN NICODEMUS: Thanks, man.
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: Ron.
RYAN NICODEMUS: Nice
to meet you, Ron.
AUDIENCE: Same here.
Here's my question,
and again, this
is kind of like the
privilege question.
It's a question about the
bigger picture, as it were.
There are I think
two forces kind
of going on and like
competing each other.
On one hand, there
are people like you,
and other well-meaning
people, who are giving people
the option, hey, you get
off this treadmill, or this,
whatever it is that you're on,
and make your priorities what
really works for you.
And that is wonderful, and
I'm very happy that you're
getting to thousands of people
and making the changes, maybe
tens of thousands of people.
On the other hand,
there is way, way,
way more budget going to telling
people if you buy my crap,
then you will be loved,
or you'll get laid,
or whatever it is that--
JOSHUA MILLBURN:
Commodified love.
AUDIENCE: I'm sorry?
JOSHUA MILLBURN: We've
commodified love.
AUDIENCE: Right, exactly.
And so you may become
successful in the sense
that you would get
to a lot of people,
but it'll be a
very niche success.
And what can we do about
this bigger picture,
because like I said, right
now, if you're on NBC,
still way more of the
time of their programming
is for that other messaging.
Yeah, it's nice, they
kind of pay their dues,
and let you talk there too.
But you know--
RYAN NICODEMUS: Yeah, I
think that what we're doing
is by nature subversive to
what you're talking about,
the culture that
you're talking about.
And I would say we're
doing it right now,
by helping to share this idea,
to share this philosophy.
Yeah, it is a very tough--
it's a tough racket, because
it is a lot of forces
that are working against us.
And of course, this is
a very biased opinion.
Because for last
seven years, I've
been talking about minimalism.
But what I see, though, is
that five-year-old, high school
kids, college kids.
And it's not just
that demographic.
It's great
grandmothers, who will
bring three generations
of daughters with them
to our events.
But what I am seeing
is people are starting
to realize that what
they're trying to be sold
isn't necessarily the
answer to happiness.
And it doesn't take
people earning six figures
to figure that out.
You're wincing, why
are you wincing?
AUDIENCE: It's just
because, in the end,
I think what most people do--
it's like the biggest effect
there, it's like that the total
sum of all the memes that go
through their brain, from one
year, and yes, people can--
some people can take
out their own thing
and kind of decide what to--
but I think in
the end, this is--
without fighting
against the problem--
you're fighting
it in a positive,
you're offering an alternative.
And you're hoping that as
many people as possible
will forego the bad
option, and take that.
RYAN NICODEMUS: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: But I'm
a little skeptical
that while this other
option is so powerful,
and kind of goes at you
from more and more avenues
and in so many
different way, I don't
think that it's really
realistic to assume
that you're going to get
there, one grandma at a time.
RYAN NICODEMUS: Yeah,
the average American
sees 5,000 bits of input a day.
Why are you giving
this back to me?
Oh, OK.
So, just real quick--
I was just going
to say the average
American sees 5,000
bits of input--
I'm sorry, 5,000
advertisements a day.
5,000 advertisements
a day when you're on--
whatever, TV, billboards,
whatever social media
you go to.
JOSHUA MILLBURN: Google Plus.
RYAN NICODEMUS:
Yes, Google Plus.
JONNY CRANMER: Sent
to you by Google.
RYAN NICODEMUS: Which I'll
say is by far like the most,
I feel like, is the
least intrusive.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
RYAN NICODEMUS: Yeah, right.
It is the least
intrusive by far.
And I'm not just saying that
because I'm here at Google.
But no, like, kudos to that,
because it is amazing how it--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] almost
as popular as you are.
RYAN NICODEMUS: Right, but
my point is that people--
the grandma, they do need a way
to filter through those 5,000
advertisements a day.
Because when we see
something on a billboard,
then in a commercial,
then whatever,
that will seep into
our subconscious,
and we do start to think like,
oh, man, if I got my partner
that really nice luxury car,
and put a big bow on it,
and surprised her for
Christmas, like that's
going to make me happy.
Or if I go on that
vacation, yeah, it's
going to make me
really, really happy.
Or yeah, if I go to
Jarod, or whatever,
if I get that big
diamond ring, like man,
she's going to be so happy.
Like we are told what is
going to make us happy.
Which is really
interesting, because
like post-industrial age,
advertisements actually
fulfilled needs.
And now we create the need.
And I think that
what we're doing
is, yes, it's helping
one person at a time.
I'm certainly not going to
get into the political realm.
I think maybe that is was where
you might be going with it.
But I think, but I guess
what I'm getting at though,
is that even if it was just
one person, even if it was just
that--
even if it was just Dee,
who came up to me and said,
dude, thank you so
much for helping me not
feel like a loser
for being poor,
that would make it all worth it.
And we are reaching
millions of people.
If you have any other grand,
big ideas, I'm totally open.
But what I focus on is
what I think is right,
and what I think is adding
the most value to the people
out there.
And that's really
what I focus on.
JOSHUA MILLBURN: Real quick, I'm
not trying to change the world.
I'm just trying to
help a little bit.
And I think companies like
this have the opportunity
to change the world.
And so I would put
it back on you.
And if each one of you
finds a way, if you're
interested in helping.
I don't think it comes
down to regulating
how many items someone can own.
Telling someone what
they can and can't have
is not going to be the answer.
The answer is going
to be for us to find
ways to help out a little bit.
And so if we can help
out a little bit,
some other people can help
out, you all can help out,
you can create
some great change.
I don't want to put a
dent in the universe,
as Steve Jobs once said.
I just want to show up
and help a little bit.
AUDIENCE: You guys,
thank you so much.
This is incredibly profound.
RYAN NICODEMUS:
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: Conrad.
RYAN NICODEMUS:
Nice to meet you.
AUDIENCE: Literally the
realist most subversive shit
I've heard in a
while, so thank you.
So five years ago, I
committed Facebook suicide,
pulled the plug.
RYAN NICODEMUS: Nice.
AUDIENCE: Gave people 48 hours.
I'm like hit me up
IRL, as the kids say.
RYAN NICODEMUS: Congrats,
by the way, that's awesome.
AUDIENCE: Fantastic.
It was liberating.
The reaction from a
pretty big set of people
was swift and fierce.
People what felt judged.
They came back at me hard.
I'm curious to know, because I'd
like to take this even further.
Did you guys-- I mean you
talked about your past,
and making some
choices about people
who weren't value aligned.
Did you get that same reaction?
How did you process
that and redirect it?
I'm curious to know how you felt
and how you moved through that.
Because I've got
to believe that you
experienced some
of the same stuff.
JOSHUA MILLBURN: For sure.
So I think there are three types
of relationships in our lives.
We have sort of our
primary relationships.
The five people that are
closest to you, 10 people
if you're Catholic.
Then you've got your secondary
relationships, people you still
really care about, love,
extended family, co-workers,
whatever.
And you have the third
tier, the periphery.
And those are people that
are still in your life,
and you care about them.
I found I was spending so
much time with that periphery,
I was spending time
with the wrong people.
And because of that,
those inner two layers,
especially the people
closest to me, they--
and they pretended they
understood, because oh, you're
out there being successful and
you're working 80 hours a week,
you know, go ahead and do that.
But the truth is that
it didn't feel good,
it didn't feel successful.
And so I had to re-prioritize
a lot of my relationships.
And in doing that,
I had to cut out
some of the
relationships in my life.
And sometimes--
sometimes we have
to let go of shitty
relationships in our lives too.
Because when I look at some of
the people in my life before,
a lot of people would
play the victim role.
And victims become
victimizers pretty quickly.
And I realized that I could try
to repair some relationships.
But there were some that
were not worth repairing.
Because I wanted
to surround myself
with people who would help me
be the ideal version of myself,
as opposed to dragging me back
down to a less ideal version.
RYAN NICODEMUS: Yeah,
when we called ourselves
the minimalists,
we found out really
quickly who our friends were.
It was shocking.
Looking back, I'm really glad
that it happened that way,
because a lot of the people who
like instantly started judging,
and I started seeing
some of that backlash,
I automatically knew who were
actually my friends and who
weren't.
And it took a lot of
tough conversations,
even with family members.
Like my mom called me up,
hey, son, how you doing?
I'm like, I'm
great, how are you?
I'm doing all right.
She's like what's
this minimalist crap?
And I was like, oh,
you found the website.
She must have been Googling
my name or something
and come across it.
And I'm like yeah,
what do you think?
And she's like, I don't really
get it, like are you depressed?
Are you not going to be
around for holidays anymore?
Can I not buy you gifts anymore?
And I'm like, well, mom,
yes, I am depressed,
and I'm trying to get out of it.
And I am using this as a way to
kind of get out of this slump
that I really feel
like I've been
in for the last several years.
And I said, no,
I will absolutely
be around for holidays.
Like, in fact, I hope to see
you more than just the holidays,
because that's about--
like I said earlier, I
only saw her a few times
a year, major holidays, maybe
Mother's Day, her birthday.
And I really want
to spend more time
having a relationship with
you, rather than focusing
on my work.
And you know when it
comes to gifts, I'm like,
yeah, you know, I'd rather
you not buy me anything.
I appreciate the
sentiment that you have,
but if it's something
that I don't need,
it's not going to
serve a purpose,
or if it's not something that's
going to make me super happy,
don't worry about spending $15
on a necktie clip or something.
And she's like, well,
I'm your mother,
and I'm still going to
buy you things anyway.
OK, I guess as my mom, she
has that right to say that.
And I'm like, mom, I just
got to be honest with you,
if you get me something
and I don't use it,
I'm going to have to
find another home for it.
I'm going to have
to donate it, I'm
going to have to give it away.
This is not the thing to say
to your mother, by the way.
She kind of reacted--
she was a little
angry, rightfully so.
And it kind of got
a little heated.
But it got to a point
where I just kind of slowed
things down.
I'm like, mom, let me just
stop you for a second.
I love you so much.
You love me, right?
She's like, yeah, of
course, I love you.
And I'm like, I want
you to be happy.
You want me to be
happy too, right?
She's like, yeah, of course
I want you to be happy.
And I said, well, if
that's the case, then what
I need from you is support.
I don't need you to
have a packing party.
I'm not going to
come to your home
and judge all the
stuff that you have.
All I need is for you to
support me on this journey
that I'm starting.
And that is what really
got through to her.
And I mimicked that conversation
with a lot of people.
And what I had to
realize too is the people
who were doing the judging--
I got rid of my Facebook
a few months ago--
and I cannot tell you
how freeing it is.
AUDIENCE: It's amazing.
RYAN NICODEMUS: Oh,
my god, it's so great.
It's unbelievable.
Hey Josh, how do you
know if someone got rid
of their Facebook?
JOSHUA MILLBURN: Don't
worry, they'll tell you.
RYAN NICODEMUS: So, I got a
little bit of the backlash
too on that.
And I just had to remind
myself, like anytime someone
is judging me, judgment
is but a mirror
that reflects the
person's insecurities
that's doing the judging.
And that is ultimately
what it comes down to.
People who are my true friends,
people who actually do love me,
they're not going
to feel judged.
They might have a
conversation with me.
They might ask me
some questions.
But they're not going to
give me that backlash.
People who love me and
want me to be happy,
they will support me.
And what I'll say
is doing something
like getting rid of
Facebook, or doing something
like calling yourself
a minimalist,
or call it simplicity.
You can call it
whatever you want.
We're the minimalists
because the domain
was available for like $8.
So call it whatever you want.
But I think doing something
like that, it is a good way
to actually see who
your true friends are,
not just to your
friends are on Facebook.
JOSHUA MILLBURN: We
have time for one more?
JONNY CRANMER: I
think, is there--
more questions?
JOSHUA MILLBURN:
One more question.
AUDIENCE: Let me see
if this is working.
OK, hi.
JOSHUA MILLBURN: Howdy.
RYAN NICODEMUS: Hello.
AUDIENCE: Well, I just
wanted to first point out
that while everyone thinks of
Google as a search company,
were actually an
advertising company.
I mean, that's really
where we make our money.
So it's kind of funny
for you guys to like say,
like we're forced into this
consumeristic society by ads.
Like, they're
forcing you to feel
like you need something, or
feel like you want something.
And were part of that.
I mean, unfortunately, our
company is part of the problem.
And that's an
unfortunate thing to say.
But I don't work in ads
anymore, so whatever.
Right in there.
But what I was going
to ask was actually
when you guys
began your journey,
and you were leaving
your positions
at your old companies, where you
were making six figure incomes,
and you were like,
hey, I'm going
to go do this other
thing, how many people
reacted to that like
you guys are crazy?
I mean, I have to feel
like it was a lot, right?
You were talking about
your Facebook friends,
and how many of them
didn't understand,
that's how you really separate
the wheat from the chaff,
right?
JOSHUA MILLBURN: They
don't believe me.
Because my initial plan, before
the whole minimalist thing took
off, was I left, and I
just wanted to be a barista
and write fiction full time.
That was my gig.
There's a coffee shop two blocks
from my apartment that I was--
I moved into this
small apartment.
And was on the way to
becoming debt free.
And then like the
whole minimalism thing
was this beautiful accident.
Because Ryan came to me,
and he was like, hey,
man, you've been writing
fiction for a long time.
Do you think that could write
some nonfiction about sort
of this journey, we
could could share it.
And that's where the
minimalist.com started,
was sort of with that journey.
And when I told
people I was just
going to go write full
time, they looked at me
and said you can't do that.
If you could just go do
that, everyone would do it.
And I'm like, you realize
there are some people who make
a living from writing, right?
Like this wouldn't be the
first time in human history
that someone became a writer.
And it was also because
they didn't understand--
I didn't say well, I'm going to
make the same amount of money.
I'm like, no, I
can live off of--
the first year I left
I made $23,000 a year.
It was like 90% less money.
But strangely, I actually
contributed more that year
in terms of charity, and
time, and stuff like that,
than I had at all in
the corporate world.
And so, yea, people--
it's not that they were
just confused by it,
they didn't believe me at first.
But, like Ryan said,
you start to figure out
who your real friends
are, and people
who just want to
associate with you
because you had a
particular job title are.
RYAN NICODEMUS: I
would say it is really
cool though to see Google--
I was talking to
Johnny about this
before we started this panel--
I feel like if every
corporation just
did a little bit of what Google
does, as far as they do put
people first in a lot of ways.
And I am not anti-capitalist
by any stretch.
But I think that the inherent
problem with capitalism
is money first.
It is bottom line first, and
maybe it's people second.
That's a problem.
And to see a company like Google
flipping that a little bit,
I think that does provide an
example for other corporations
to do that.
You're right, corporations,
they are inherently dangerous,
for sure.
Because they do
contribute to the problem.
But it would be nice to see
other corporations putting
people first, before
that bottom line.
Like some of the programs
you guys have are amazing.
Like what you do with
the profits, like the--
what is it called?
JONNY CRANMER: Project Lane.
RYAN NICODEMUS:
Yeah, Project Lane,
like that is such a cool thing.
Or the air drop thing you
were telling me about.
JONNY CRANMER: The drones.
RYAN NICODEMUS:
Yeah, the drones,
dropping supplies and things,
that other third world
countries need.
That's amazing.
I can only imagine if
every company put that
into their work atmosphere.
JOSHUA MILLBURN: There's nothing
inherintly wrong with money.
Ryan and I aren't
allergic to money.
And the question is what
do we do with our money.
I no longer-- money is no
longer the primary driver
for doing what I do.
But whenever you're making
a business decision,
it still has to be part of it.
I can't go on tour
and perpetually
lose money forever, right?
That's just a bad
business decision.
So then the question
is, how can I
do this so that it does
align with my values,
and also make some money
on it, and then a I
do some really cool
stuff with that money.
So Ryan and I have
built orphanages,
we've funded high
schools, we've contributed
to terrorist victims, things
like that, where we couldn't
have done that without money.
And so money allows
you to buy a Ferrari,
or allows you to do
something really cool
to contribute to the world
beyond you in a meaningful way.
AUDIENCE: That reminds me,
this month is Google Serve.
So if you haven't signed
up for a project yet,
Google lets you have 20
hours of your work time
to go volunteer
for building houses
with the Habitat for Humanity,
and beach clean-up, and all
this stuff.
We're doing that in June.
JOSHUA MILLBURN: That's killer.
RYAN NICODEMUS:
That is very cool.
AUDIENCE: If you
haven't volunteered yet,
you should try to sign up
for something this month.
RYAN NICODEMUS: Is that what
the volunteer shirts are?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
RYAN NICODEMUS: OK, very cool.
JOSHUA MILLBURN: Awesome,
thank you for that.
RYAN NICODEMUS: See, that's
a meaningful T-shirt.
JONNY CRANMER: Guys,
thanks you so much.
I know that we've come to time.
JOSHUA MILLBURN: Thanks guys.
RYAN NICODEMUS: Give
me a hug, brother.
JONNY CRANMER: Yeah.